good afternoon good afternoon everyone
my name is David Bob I serve as director
of the Allen P Kirby jr. center for
constitutional studies and citizenship
Hillsdale College
so our pleasure today to welcome you to
this lecture launched in 2008 and
located on Capitol Hill the Kirby Center
teaches the principles and practice of
American constitutionalism in the
nation's capital and around the country
welcome to today's first principles on
first Friday's lecture it's part of a
lecture series that now has been going
since late 2008 that addresses
significant and timely political
historical and economic topics from a
constitutional perspective today we're
pleased to have as our speaker Andrew
McCarthy he's spoken for Hillsdale
College on a number of occasions and
always brings with him a hard-hitting
moral and political acuity that
challenges his audiences his topic today
is an important one and were grateful
for the incisive commentary he offers
regularly at National Review Online
where if you have not seen his regular
commentaries and blog postings I would
urge you to check those out in addition
to those writings he's also written
extensively and I wanted to mention
before the formal introduction is
offered by one of our Hillsdale College
students a couple of those recent
publications in the American tradition
the broadside a small pamphlet like
publication has a long and distinguished
history recently in encounter books has
revived that and has published a series
of of commentaries this one by Andy
McCarthy is titled how Obama embraces
Islam's Sharia agenda you might check
out his other books then willful
blindness
a memoir of the jihad and then most
recently the grand jihad how Islam and
the left sabotage America Hillsdale
College senior Celia Bigelow an
economics major is interning this
semester at Freedom Works she's
participating in the Washington
Hillsdale internship program which for
forty years now has sent Hillsdale
College students to Washington DC in a
program that we now like to joke is a
kind of study abroad program in keeping
with hills dales tradition of students
introducing speakers for the college I
would like to now call upon Celia to
introduce our speaker Celia
Thank You dr. Bob welcome and good
morning Andrew C McCarthy as a senior
fellow at the national review Institute
for 18 years he was an assistant US
attorney in the South District of New
York and from 1993 to 1995 he led the
Terrorism prosecution against Sheikh
Omar Abdul Rahman and 11 others in
connection with the 1993 World Trade
Center bombings in New York and the plot
to bomb other New York City landmarks
following the September 11th attacks he
supervised the Justice Department's
command post near Ground Zero he also
served as a special assistant to deputy
secretary of defense and as an adjunct
professor at Fordham University's Law
School and New York University's Law
School mr. McCarthy writes widely for
newspapers and journals and is author of
two books grand jihad how Islam in the
last sabotage America and willful
blindness a memoir of the jihad today he
will be speaking on the topic global
threat of the Muslim Brotherhood please
join me in welcoming mr. Andrew McCarthy
thank you thank you so much I love to
come back to Hillsdale and I'm always
happy when I get invited back because as
you might imagine most of the time when
I speak at a college it's not a home
game and and today sort of feels like
one which is the way it always feels at
Hillsdale so I'm delighted to be here
and and honored to be here what I'd like
to talk today about is the Muslim
Brotherhood and I'd like to do it
against a historical context once upon a
time there were two very different
visions of what the future would hold
for the Muslim world
it was nearly a century ago in the 1920s
in the aftermath of the first First
World War the first visionary was
Mustafa Kemal better known to us as
Ataturk he looked at the destruction
around him at the fact that the mighty
Ottoman Empire had been shattered and
its remnants divvied up by the new
dominant Western powers auditer
concluded that if there was to be a
resurgence in his beloved Turkey it
would have to embrace Turkey would have
to embrace the modern world it would
have to embrace the West and its
animating traditions of enlightened
reason necessarily that meant Islam the
predominant cultural force the
predominant fact of Turkish life would
have to be purged not purged entirely
but ended as the pulse of civic life
there would be need there would need to
be a western-style separation in this
case a separation of mosque and state
civil society would become a secular
space unmoored from the constraints of
Sharia Islam's static and oppressive
legal system the Caliphate now merely
symbolic as a vestige of its former
Majesty would have to be formally
dismantled now out of Turk was a Muslim
and he knew full well that his vision
for the future was antithetical to
Islam's premise that
there can be no division between the
secular and the sacred between civic
life and spiritual life he understood
that Islam was not so much a religion as
a comprehensive social system it's
imperative is to organize all of society
and to dominate it not to coexist with
other systems or assume a subordinate
role in civic life that's why for
example ensure Iran and in the Sunni
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia the official law
is the Quran the hadith and other
authorized biographies and sources of
biographies of Muhammad and sources of
Islamic Scripture nothing else but
Sharia the law of Allah is thought to be
necessary to control everything from
finance to governance to domestic
relations to military operations to
Foreign Affairs Sharia covers the full
expanse of life from matters of hygiene
to inquiries about the nature of the
divine Ataturk knew then that to drive
Islam out of the public square to box it
into an unnatural spiritual cabin would
require rigorous relentless attention he
was seeking to revise not just a culture
but a civilization consequently he
vigorously repressed Islam he realized
it was not spontaneously moderate and
tolerant to make it in that mould to
remake it would require severe state
action the Turkish government thus
purged Islam from the public square and
marginalised it in the classroom even in
the spiritual realm the new secular
Turkey was taking no chances the state
took control of the country's 80,000
mosques it vetted Imams
controlling the content of their sermons
and the literature they disseminated the
state endorsed the management of
charitable and I'm sorry the state
assumed the management of charitable
endowments steering funds away from
jihadist causes it even regulated trips
to mecca for turks who were seeking to
fulfill the hajj pilgrimage that all
able-bodied muslims are obliged
to make the secularists feared that the
influence of Saudi Arabia's
unadulterated form of Islam would be
dangerous for Turks who traveled to
Saudi Arabian finally because he knew he
would not live forever
auda Turk erected a legal and political
framework to ensure the permanent
shackling of Islam or so he thought it's
an interesting departure from our own
experience the United States is a
pluralist society that provides freedom
of religion Autotech was looking to
foster pluralism in an overwhelmingly
Muslim society so instead he imposed a
French model of life suit a freedom from
religion the complete banning of Sharia
from legal and social policy finally the
role of the military intelligence and
police forces was elevated together they
formed the most secular and the most
ruthlessly reliable institution in
Turkish life by Constitution they would
now be made the secular societies
constant Guardian their highest duty
equal in importance to protecting the
nation from hostile outsiders would be
to stand guard against Islamist sedition
from within they would be empowered to
oust any civilian government that turned
away from auda Turks program and in fact
they did exactly that several times
before the turn of the century now
remember I said that there were two
visions of the future well as you might
imagine these developments in Turkey
absolutely horrified the second
visionary who is the main consideration
for today the principle that you the
principle person you need to consider in
any consideration of the Muslim
Brotherhood Hassan al-banna was a pious
charismatic teacher a man of great
passion shrewdness bottomless energy and
virulent contempt for the West from
Egypt he grew increasingly enraged by
what was happening in Turkey to Bona the
explanation for the disap
condition of the Muslim world was not
too much Islam that was precisely the
opposite for bonad there had been too
little Islam and in particular too
little of what he considered to be the
right kind of Islam bono was a student
of Salafism a reformist Islam that aimed
to return Muslims to the principles of
the founding generations to the ideology
of Muhammad Islam's warrior prophet -
that ideology as it was understood and
applied by the salafiyyah
the rightly guided caliphs the Salafi ax
had been the prophet's first and most
faithful successors they had steered the
ummah which is the notional worldwide
muslim community from a fringe desert
movement to domination over much of the
known world salafism is the backbone of
the muslim brotherhood the organization
that bhana organized and established
first in 1928 it's essential that we do
not caricature this belief system too
often i think americans are dismissive
of Islamist ideology perhaps that's
because foolishly our government has
encouraged us for almost 20 years to
ignore the otherwise undeniable facts
that this ideology is derived from a
very mainstream interpretation of
Islamic Scripture and that it fuels the
global phenomenon of Islamist terror or
maybe we are dismissive because almost
everything we think we know about
Islamist ideology is wrong
ideology is not all backward anti Reason
anti science and anti modernity even
though that is the way it is often
caricature that criticism might have
more force if we were talking about
Wahhabism the fundamentalist islam that
is the official creed of saudi arabia
but that is not the Brotherhood and in
fact the Muslim Brotherhood has done a
good deal to evolve Wahhabism over the
last half-century plus beginning in the
1950s and the 1960s when many of the
brothers in Egypt actually fled
from persecution under the NASA regime
and found a soft place to land in Saudi
Arabian banas cell if this program is
thoughtful and highly sophisticated
because it seeks to destroy it but I'm
sorry because it seeks to destroy us we
underestimate it at our great peril
Egyptian salafists did not reject
modernity they sought to dominate
modernity yes they are Sharia
determinists nothing is permissible
outside the framework of allah's law but
within the retrograde constraints of
that framework of sharia they do favour
scientific inquiry and economic
productivity yes they reject the
judeo-christian veneration of reason in
our understanding of faith too much
reason they argue is not reason at all
it's just a rationalization for
sidestepping the requirements of Allah's
law but they do not reject reason
entirely they granted an important role
in deciding which Islamic principles
apply in any given situation the problem
with the system it's a closed system it
has to be Islamic principles deciding
everything now why do I say that bonnez
program which to this day by the way
remains the muslim brotherhood's program
why do I say that it seeks to destroy us
well for one thing the Muslim
Brotherhood tells us as much
bhana made it quite clear that he
considered Western civilization to be
the enemy of Islamic civilization they
would not coexist ultimately one or the
other would have to prevail if Islamic
civilization and what we call Islamist
ideology are as the Brotherhood defines
them then surely vana was right about
this the Muslim Brotherhood's official
motto has never been altered since the
organization's inception Allah is our
objective the Prophet is our leader the
Quran is our law jihad is our way and
dying in the way of Allah is our highest
hope Allahu Akbar which means God is the
greatest
the mono tells us many things but two
are especially significant first the
Quran is our law the Muslim
Brotherhood's operating imperative is to
implement and spread Sharia in
Brotherhood ideology Sharia is the
necessary precondition to Islam izing a
society you frequently hear Islamist
apologist in the West cite a verse of
the Quran that says there shall be no
compulsion in matters of religion CER
told it is contrary to Islamic
principles to force conversions but you
need to read the fine print is Lamas may
not convert you at the point of a gun
but they are perfectly willing to impose
Sharia by any means necessary
Sharia does not force non-muslims to
accept Islam we're told and that's true
but you must accept the authority of the
Islamic state and you must pay a tax for
the privilege of living as a non-muslim
in a Sharia Territory oh and the Quran
declares that you must feel yourself
subdued in submitting to the authority
of the Islamic state this is the
humiliation of dhimmitude paying for the
privilege of being permitted to continue
adhering to your current religious faith
the privilege by the way comes with
severe restrictions they're designed to
make Islam always appear to be the
better option the idea is that force
conversions won't be necessary because
once sharia is imposed everyone will see
the good sense in becoming a muslim and
what could be more moderate than that
the second thing the Brotherhood's motto
demonstrates to us is the centrality of
jihad to the islamist mission it's
really quite amazing that here we are
almost two full decades after the
bombing of the World Trade Center
having just observed the tenth
anniversary or the tenth annual
commemoration of the 9/11 attacks and
yet Americans still really don't
understand what jihad is the word
literally means struggle some of my
allies on the national security right
will tell you that jihad is
strictly a combat mission involving
terrorist attacks and essentially being
a military campaign only and exclusively
against the enemies of Islam it can be
terrorist attacks or it can be a formal
military campaign if the Sharia State
has the resources for that but the idea
is that it's only violence and nothing
but violence then there are others
including some of the top national
security advisors in the current
administration who tell you that that's
all old hat what they call the lesser
jihad the greater jihad the real jihad
they tell you is the internal struggle
to become a better person or maybe a
neighborhoods collective struggle to rid
itself of bad influences like drug
trafficking its smiley face jihad in
fact I think if you listen to these
folks long enough you come away thinking
that jihad is the internal struggle to
remember to brush after every meal
neither one of these depictions is
correct though they both have a kernel
of truth to them you have to think of
jihad against the backdrop of the
Islamists primary mission which is to
make Islam dominant in that crucial
context jihad is always and everywhere
the struggle to establish and spread
Sharia the legal and political
foundation of Islamic society once
you've got that down the rest is easy it
is true that jihad originated as
primarily a military mission recall that
Islam advanced by conquest at least in
the main not by peaceful persuasion and
in making that observation I'm not
attempting to whitewash the legacy of
violence or coercion that that is part
of judeo-christian history I'm merely
making a statement of fact Islam was
spread by the sword but the fact that
jihad was primarily violent does not
mean that it was exclusively violent
there's no need to engage in violence if
the other side is willing to cede
territory or submit to other demands so
yes
it has a military component but it's not
exclusively a military component and yes
there is a personal struggle and a
communal aspect of jihad but it is
salient ly different from what you hear
from administration officials jihad is
not the internal struggle to become a
better person it's the internal struggle
to become a better Muslim and that's a
very different thing involving faith
fidelity to the principles of Islam
involving compliance with Allah's law
jihad is an Islamic concept in terms of
a personal component to it it has to be
viewed in that context in communal terms
jihad is not a neighborhood struggled to
rid itself of bad influences bad again
suggests universal ideas and we're not
talking about a universal concept we're
talking about a very distinct Islamic
concept so what it really means is a
neighborhood struggle to rid itself of
non-islamic influences to become more
pure in a Sharia sense so jihad is about
spreading Sharia and living Sharia why
should that be of concern to us because
classical mainstream Sharia contains
several tenants that are completely
antithetical to American constitutional
republicanism and to Western culture
classical Sharia denies the foundational
premise of our free society that the
people have a right to chart their own
destiny and to make law for their own
society irrespective of Sharia or any
other legal code in Islamist ideology no
law may contradict Sharia Sharia denies
freedom of conscience apostasy the
renunciation of Islam is considered the
highest form of treason it's punishable
by death
Sharia denies equality before the law
equality between men and women equality
between Muslims and non-muslims Sharia
rejects American and Western notions of
privacy homosexuality for example is a
capital offense punishable by death
women are whipped
for everything from driving cars to
socializing with men who are not their
relatives Shariah departs from American
principles of economic Liberty all
property is deemed to belong to Allah
the nominal property owners are better
understood as custodians and their
holdings are subject to what the Islamic
state determines the society needs
Sharia prohibits finance capitalism the
charging or paying of interest is
forbidden and the state is encouraged to
enforce economic equality of results by
redistributing wealth Shariah rejects
free expression criticism of Islam is
strictly prohibited as is any form of
speech that would tend to sow dissension
among the Ummah and truth is not a
defense Shariah features draconian
penalties that defy our freedom from
cruel and unusual punishments stoning
lashing and beheading remain permissible
penalties as we saw in auda Turks
experiment and secularization Sharia
rejects the separation of the sacred and
secular orders it establishes Islam as
the state religion and requires
recognition of Sharia as the highest
form of law a form of law that seeks not
merely to prescribe spiritual principles
but to control every aspect of life and
sharia approves the settlement of
disputes by violence whenever violence
is unnecessary and productive means of
advancing a laws cause this is the
Muslim Brotherhood's agenda wherever on
earth it operates and you should know
that it now operates across the globe it
is not a dream because Hassan al-banna
was no dreamer he had a very practical
patient multifaceted plan for achieving
the Brotherhood's goal of a universal
Caliphate a world dominated by Islam it
was a blueprint for revolution from the
ground up starting with the Muslim
individual and building out from there
to the Muslim family the community the
town the city the region and be
at each sage there was to be preparation
for jihad including violent jihad there
was emphasis on military training and
even on suicide attacks which are
regarded as what they call martyrdom
operations'
but there's a very important difference
between the Brotherhood and terrorist
organizations like al-qaeda they are in
complete agreement it should be stressed
on what the bottom line is they're both
trying to get to the same place and they
certainly for all the people who tell
you that there's great tension between
the Brotherhood and al-qaeda they have a
lot more in common with each other than
they have with us either of them but but
here's the difference comparatively
speaking al-qaeda is a crude
extortionate Network it basically wants
to bludgeon you into accepting Sharia it
has no interest in negotiating or
working with non Islamic governments it
regards them as enemies of Islam and it
believes that sitting down with them in
any way legitimizes them the Brotherhood
is much more sophisticated for bhana
violent jihad was just one item on a
menu of options yes the Brotherhood
trains for violence and it does
ultimately see violence as inevitable
Hamas after all a ruthless terrorist
organization is actually the Palestinian
branch of the Muslim Brotherhood but the
Brotherhood endorses violence only when
violence will have the net effect of
advancing the cause let me give you an
example sheikh yusuf kara Dowie
is the Brotherhood's leading
jurisprudent and he's probably the most
influential Islamic Sunni cleric in the
world he condemned the 9/11 attacks and
predictably this had all the apologists
in the West going up in a balloon
because they desperately want to see
Kerry dally and the Brotherhood as
moderate modernizers but a very short
time after that kara Dowie issued
another fatwa calling for terrorist
attacks against Americans in in Iraq
just as he had long approved of suicide
attacks in Israel we seem to scratch our
head
that we what we think of as a
contradiction but it would be easily
explained if we would just study the
ideology of our enemies the United
States is not an Islamic country yet it
is a country where the Brotherhood has
been very successful in raising money
for Hamas in particular in propagating
Islamist ideology and in slowly
advancing the toleration of Sharia
principles in our law our culture and
our financial sector they have a very
good thing going here
the 9/11 attacks set the cause backwards
because they provoked an overwhelming
response the United States militarily
invaded and occupied Islamic countries
and on the home front the activities of
Islamist organization suddenly had a
scrutiny that they had escaped for a
long time before carried ah we condemned
9/11 not because violence is immoral but
because in these circumstances it was
counterproductive it was a tactical
condemnation not a theoretical one by
contrast Iraq is a Muslim country and
Israel is a territory that Islam is
considered to be Muslim land regardless
of whether we see that claim as legally
or historically accurate under Sharia
when non-muslim forces occupy an Islamic
territory Muslims are under an
obligation to attack until they drive
the outside forces out of the country
and it does not matter in the slightest
that the Western forces if they are
Western forces think that they're doing
humanitarian work to make the lives of
Muslims better under Sharia the planting
of Western institutions and Western
concepts is deemed to be a provocative
act of war and even if we think we're
trying to make things better for them
they take it as hostile for the
Brotherhood the plan is to do anything
that works to advance the cause they use
violence when violence works they reject
violence when violence seems
counterproductive under the
circumstances but in the meantime
there's always a lot of other menu items
going on
bhana believed it was just as important
in terms as being prepared for violent
jihad to control the classroom to
cultivate the media to rise to
leadership positions in all of a
society's major institutions and to
collaborate with governments and by
collaborate I don't just mean to
cultivate government officials and work
with them and try to persuade them to
accept Islam friendly policies the
Brotherhood also wants to infiltrate
government to bore inside directly
influence the council's of policy and
Islam eyes a nation from within it's a
very comprehensive program it's designer
was no fool he knew it would take a very
long time but when you're on a divine
mission you've got as much time as it
takes in Muslim countries the movement
is in a bigger hurry because it has the
critical mass of people necessary to
make sweeping changes we're beginning to
see that throughout the Middle East what
we in America like to think of as the
Arab Spring
is nothing of the kind it's an Islamist
ascendancy does that mean there are no
secular Democrats and no Muslim
reformers in Islamic countries no of
course not but we should not kid
ourselves the Reformers and the
secularists and the Democrats are vastly
outnumbered by the Islamists I think
that's something that gets obscured by
the people who want to see this as the
Arab Spring because they compare the
number of Democrats and secularists with
the number of terrorists but we're not
just talking about terrorists we're
talking about Islamists we're talking
about people who want to live under
Sharia law in Sharia States and reliable
polling is done in that region of the
world and that polling tells us that
well upwards of half the people want to
live under Sharia systems and depending
on when where you ask the question if
you ask it say in Saudi Arabia or Egypt
or Pakistan the number is not 50% or 60%
it's more like 80% and upward so I'm not
trying to suggest or denigrate the the
people in the Middle East who are trying
to
democratic reform I'm just saying that
we need to do it with our eyes open and
not over ate what it is what I think
eventually will happen given the dynamic
I just described is that we will see the
Muslim Brotherhood in the forefront of
the movements that are rising throughout
these different Islamic countries the
Muslim Brotherhood's now poised to take
over Egypt it will be the dynamic power
center in libyan if assad finally Falls
in Syria the Brotherhood will be there
to pick up the pieces it's on the rise
the Brotherhood is on the rise every
place in the Middle East where the
dominoes are falling and that every
place very much includes Turkey odda
Turks vision is now a faded memory by a
quirk of election law that was actually
designed to keep Islamists out of power
an Islamic faction was actually elected
in 2002 the Prime Minister Recep Erdogan
is a close Confederate of the Muslim
Brotherhood
he has steadily moved the country back
into the Islamist camp hollowing out the
military and the other institutions that
auditor believed would be the bulwark
against Sharia after almost a century
bhana has his victory over Ataturk and
if it happened in Turkey how quickly do
you suppose it's going to happen in
Muslim countries that have not repressed
Islam within with an 80 year
secularization program I think we need
to be realistic about what's happening
there the plan in the West is different
it's been called voluntary apartheid the
Brotherhood urges Muslims to integrate
but don't assimilate the objective is to
establish Islamic enclaves initially
small but growing in various precincts
and in those places
Sharia will drive competitors out and
become the law of the land that's the
method by which Sheikh Qaradawi openly
and brazenly claims we will conquer
Europe and we will conquer America those
are his words not
in Europe it's working after decades of
uncontrolled immigration particularly
from North Africa and South Asia the
continent is now dotted by what the
authority's reluctant reluctantly refer
to as no-go zones these are Islamic
enclaves where police firefighters
ambulances and other agents of state
power no longer enter they fear for
their safety in essence these countries
have ceded their sovereignty over these
places to the local Muslim Imams and
elders functionally and certainly in
Muslim eyes these enclaves townships and
even some cities are no longer parts of
England France Germany Sweden and other
nations of Europe they have been claimed
for Islam and the umma has no intention
of giving them back the United States is
different for now at least our local
governments have not surrendered their
authority or their sovereignty there are
troubling indications here and there but
nothing like Europe at least for now
our Achilles heel however is our law is
Lamas are becoming increasingly expert
at using our openness and our
constitutional commitment to equality as
a sword to gain acceptance of Sharia
principles in our law so for example in
Muslim Dearborn Michigan or heavily
Muslim Dearborn Michigan maybe did I
Freudian slip right in Dearborn Michigan
that's safer right event evangelical
preachers are were arrested on a public
street outside an Arab festival what was
their crime they were handing out copies
of Saint John's gospel to passers-by
they were prosecuted for disturbing the
peace
and fortunately they were acquitted but
the case should never have happened in
the first place they were engaged in
what was clearly First Amendment
protected activity unexceptional
activity in the American experience
the only disturbance was the potential
for violence by Muslims reacting to what
they were doing in effect the police
were enforcing Sharia is prohibition
against preaching religions other than
Islam and in and against encouraging
Muslims to convert or at least explore
other religions in New Jersey a judge
denied a protective order to a Muslim
woman who was being serially raped by
her Muslim husband who she was trying to
divorce there was no question that the
man had forced himself against them on
the woman against her will but in Sharia
there can be no marital rape because the
woman is required to submit to her
husband whenever he demands it the judge
declined to issue the protective order
reasoning that the husband was just
following Islamic principles as he
understood them fortunately that case
was reversed on appeal but there are
other cases popping up throughout the
country and we now have a thriving
Sharia finance industry its vigorously
supported by universities like
Georgetown and Harvard which have
received tens of millions of dollars in
support from the Saudi government in
Minnesota you can even get a Muslim
mortgage the state will intervene in a
sale of property will promote Islam by
structuring the transaction in a way
that payments are not considered to be
interest and therefore don't run afoul
of Sharia imagine state power being used
to that effect for any other religion in
the United States in 2009 the Obama
administration even joined Islamic
countries in proposing a United Nations
resolution that would encourage member
states to crackdown using their criminal
law on speech that could provoke
hostility to religion translation speech
that cast Islam in a poor light that
this proposal manifestly violated the
First Amendment does not seem to have
caused the slightest degree of
hesitation Islamists are on the march in
the United States because the Muslim
Brotherhood has been here for over half
a century it began its Islamic
infrastructure in this country in the
early 1960s with the Muslim Students
associations they started with just a
handful of students in the Midwest there
are now between five
and 600 chapters throughout the United
States and Canada and their mission is
to groom activists for the Muslim
Brotherhood or at least the Muslim
Brotherhood's affiliates in 2008 many of
the best-known Islamic organizations in
the United States were tied to a
years-long
Muslim Brotherhood directed scheme to
finance Hamas a criminal conspiracy in
which millions of dollars were routed
from the United States to Palestinian
terrorists perhaps the most critical
piece of evidence in that case was a
1991 memorandum that the FBI located in
the home of the Muslim Brotherhood
activists in Virginia it was written by
the Brotherhood's leadership in the
United States - the Brotherhood's global
leadership in Egypt and its purpose was
to explain what the American brothers
saw as their mission here this is what
they said as the American brothers
explained it their mission was thought
of as a grand jihad its purpose was to
eliminate and destroy Western
civilization from within by sabotage you
could not find a more faithful statement
of Hassan Albano's vision in the United
States and around the globe I'm afraid
that vision is very much alive thank you
very much for your attention
thank you yes we have time for a few
questions
yeah I'm told that I'm supposed to ask
you to wait for the microphone to push
your question but sir mr. McCarthy my
name is Robert the true Zach I'm a
former prosecutor myself I've read your
book the grand jihad I've read some of
your articles in the Washington
Washington Examiner and you don't have
an arrest warrant to I no longer carry a
badge it's been a long time I was
happily retired until until I read your
book and now I'm coming back make it my
comeback so I've read your book and read
your articles
I studied the appellate opinion in the
case of us versus Robin your great
accomplishment as a prosecutor putting
away the blind Sheik I can't help but
conclude that there is a massive
seditious conspiracy and direct
violation of federal law then its object
is the overthrow of our government
nothing less and yet our government is
doing nothing do you disagree with that
well it's a very serious question it
depends on whether we're gonna whether
we take the popular definition of
sedition or the statutory definition
remember that seditious conspiracy
statute that you talk about the word
sedition only appears in the title it
doesn't appear in any of the of the
subsections and what you have to do in
order to violate that section is levy
war against the United States or use
force against the government that has to
be the conspiracy if you listen to the
Muslim Brotherhood people very often
they will disavow any intention to use
force in the United States now in my
mind if someone is trying to overthrow
our constitutional system and supplant
it with
Shriya that is seditious but it's not
it's not necessarily violence sedition
that would be cognizable under the
statute that you're talking about let me
use your question though to make a
broader point if I may I'm not a big fan
of a lot of these proposals to pass laws
to crack down on Sharia I wouldn't like
to see us be France where they they've
now you know years after the horse is
already out of the barn now they're
gonna ban the burqa and do all this
other stuff where I think the mistake is
and the reason I've written the books
you were kind enough to refer to is
because I think we oughta let America
work and what we haven't done for the
last 20 years is what we have done for
the last 20 years with what the
government has done is taken any
consideration of Islamist ideology off
the table so that where we're supposed
to understand that these terrorist
events happen that they're committed for
some irrational reason that they have no
connection whatsoever to any
interpretation of Islamic ideology and
isn't that convenient because if you're
the left it happens to be the left it
could be anyone but if you're the left
if Islamic ideology or Islamist ideology
is not closing terrorism then you get to
fill in the blank of what must be the
cause so it turns out to be Military
Commissions or Israel or or you know
poverty Gitmo Israel I mentioned Israel
right so you know I think a lot of
people think that we can't talk about
Islamist ideology because that will make
us be at war with Islam which i think is
a loopy idea and then there are
insidious people who like the idea that
you can't consider Islamist ideology
because then they get to say that what
causes terrorism is anything that they
just happen to be against - but my view
of it is for the and I laid out some of
the the really troublesome aspects of
Sharia law when you stack it up against
our notions of freedom and liberty I
think if we talked about is
honest ideology if we made our our
dividing line between who's a moderate
and who's not to be something other than
terrorism I mean basically in this
country I learned this when I was a
prosecutor a moderate was a Muslim who
was out of ammunition basically I mean
that was bad and but-but-but essentially
the way we've defined it you know a
moderate is is viewed only in the
context of terrorism so that if you're
not planning to blow up a bridge this
minute you're a moderate even if you
want to throw the United States
Constitution overboard it and replace it
with Sharia I think if we looked at
their ideology and we looked at Sharia
and we made them defend it in the light
of day you know explain to us why you
think the governed don't have a right to
make law for themselves well why men and
women aren't equal why apostasy should
be a capital offense if we talked about
it that would be a marginal ideology in
the United States it would have no
traction you wouldn't have to pass laws
against it because it would have no
following and the best thing it would do
to the extent that we have a real
interest in seeing that real authentic
moderate Western loving patriotic
American Muslims the kind that we
couldn't have infiltrated terrorist
organizations without in the 90s to the
extent that we want those people to win
the only way they win is if we
marginalize the crazies who want to
impose Sharia so I think the big mistake
is is not talking about it and I think
if we talked about it broadly we
wouldn't have to pass laws against it
and I'm really leery and I feel very
comfortable saying this at Hillsdale of
the notion that we want the law to pull
the society along rather than the other
way around hold on for the mic
yes my name is Linda Miller and what is
your opinion of the movement American
law for American courts I'm of two minds
on that number one I think that if a
state wants to outlaw its courts from
resorting to Sharia law or any other
body of law outside the law of the
United States in order to interpret its
Constitution and its statutes that don't
otherwise invoke international law
principles that a state has the right to
do that
and if those laws are going to be
written I would like to see them written
in a way that will hold up in court that
you know be written in a way that that
takes into account what the obvious
constitutional objections are and and
accounts for them and is written in a
way that has a good chance to hold up
because I think these courts are likely
to be hostile to these kind of
initiatives I think we're already seeing
that so that's my view of it legally
tactically I think it's a mistake to
provoke an argument about Sharia law
under circumstances where a most people
don't yet know what Sharia is and don't
appreciate what the threat is and be
you're dealing with states that actually
haven't had any decisions where judges
tried to impose Sharia law so it's a
potential problem I think for tactically
for Farrar side for those of us who
worry about Sharia it would be better to
have these fights under circumstances
where like in New Jersey you have a real
terrible case where where you see the
the awful effect of infiltrating Sharia
law into your system and you have a
judge who's actually accepted it so that
it's you know it's not an abstraction
it's actually a concrete problem I think
that's a lot easier to have this
argument
right
yeah Rachelle Nakia drafted a law you
read that mm-hmm i-i've seen it I think
very highly of your ashell me and if
we're gonna have these laws I want good
lawyers like David yo show me to to
write them I just question whether we
actually need to have them Mike my thing
is I want to see us have a robust
discussion in the light of day of Sharia
and I wonder how necessary this would
all be well I think that moves outside
of Sharia it incorporates Sharia but
it's also transnational law that that
will be not acceptable in our car no but
then let's have a conversation about
that a lot of America the the use by the
courts of international law to interpret
the American Constitution is in my mind
outrageous but even if I'm wrong about
that it's important and we ought to have
a debate about that I wouldn't want to
have it slipstream behind a Sharia
debate that's that's an important thing
unto itself I think thank you Andy for
your honorable and brave continuing
service thank you both in this
administration and in the past one at
the highest levels it seems to many of
us that the existential threat posed by
what you're describing has not been
understood folks like yourself james
Woolsey generals Boykin David never saw
me other other folks who put together
Team B to Sharia threat reports
certainly see that threat couple
thoughts on that do you believe that in
this administration and the prior ones
the senior folks who don't seem to
understand the threat really don't
understand the ideological basis for it
or if they do that they believe that
there won't be enough people to act upon
it and then finally for all of us here
those with whom we send messages to the
sort of body of people below the surface
who in many cases just don't want to pop
their heads up either because of work
threat the family and like what can we
do well I mentioned this in my talk but
you know you have people at the highest
level of the intelligence community in
this administration who have told look
people in the eye and tell him that you
know Sharia is the internal struggle to
become a better person and you know I
wish that were true and and look there's
a lot of there are serious Islamic
reformers who are trying to move and
evolve things in that direction and I
wish them well but we have to protect
the country regardless of whether
they're right or wrong or whether they
win or not and you can't protect the
country without understanding the
enemy's ideology and here's the problem
they want to make you think that again
moderate it's its terrorists or moderate
those are the two camps and it's so it's
so much not that and here's I think the
best example of it if you asked people
in the Islamic world would you adhere to
a interpretation of Islam in which it
would be proper to kill even Muslims who
did not subscribe to that that
interpretation of it that is a fringe
proposition in the Muslim world you when
you ask that question you get maybe
eight percent ten percent now to me by
the way if you do the math it's 1.4
billion people so that's a frightening
ly large number of people but but let's
put that on on the side for a second if
you change the question and you say do
you want to live under Sharia or should
Israel exist or is it appropriate to
kill Western forces that operate in
Islamic countries even if they think
they're doing humanitarian work those
are an eight or ten percent propositions
in the Muslim world they should be it
suddenly then goes to 50 60 70 80 %
depending on where you ask the question
what that says to me is that if we talk
about Islamist ideology rather than
jihadist terror this is a mainstream
interpretation of Islam Sharia which you
know when you hear people in the West
talk about Sharia particularly in places
that the Saudis have bought and paid for
you get this sense that all Sharia is
just this wonderful aspirational set of
spiritual guideline it's not Sharia is
accessible Sharia is the law of Saudi
Arabia it's the law of Iran it's not you
know when they stone somebody for
violating the law of Sharia they're not
throwing aspirations at the woman it's
its rocks you know they have a manual
which you can buy on Amazon I did it
myself called reliance of the traveler
it's the classical manual of Sharia law
it's been accepted by al-azhar
university which is the center of
learning in the sunni world it's also by
the way where people like the blind
shake and shake herod Ali became doctors
of Islamic jurisprudence which which is
the source of their authority over these
groups but my point is that this is not
this is not like some big hazy mirage
this ideology is very mainstream in the
Muslim world it's not up to me to say
whether it's the true Islam or not
that's beside the point I care about
American national security
I would love not to care about Islam at
all and it doesn't matter to me if the
Islamists and the Muslim Brotherhood
have Islam exactly right
or if somebody else has a better idea
about it all that matters to me is it's
not a fringe ideology it's a very
mainstream and therefore it's it's a
threat to us and we have to deal with it
as such and you can't deal with a threat
and protect the country effectively if
you pretend that's something that is
mainstream and has literally hundreds of
millions of adherents is what I used to
hear in the Justice Department which is
that it's a you know a fringe collection
of loony birds in Jersey City and if we
just got rid of them everything would be
peachy which is just not the case
talk about it make your putt make your
political representatives understand
that we want to talk about it we're not
asking them to outlaw it we're not
asking them to you know no one's asking
you to go on on public television or or
even television that people actually
watch and and and and torch a Koran or
anything we're not we don't want that
we're not interested in that we want to
talk about it though we want to be
treated like adults we don't want to be
we don't want to have people who are
supposed to be looking out for us and be
our representatives pretending that
something is just a fringe small problem
when it's a much bigger problem and I
really do think that the way to defeat
this is to let the American system work
the way the American systems supposed to
work which is we expose it in the light
of day sir in the back I am you talked a
little bit about polling and the support
of Sharia law and how it's you know 60
80 % it kind of struck me you know
Sharia law is very intolerant of women's
rights how much of that polling actually
are they asking women if they want to
live under Sharia law that's a great
it's a great question on you know that
they the polling that I have seen
purports to be a cross-section of the
Muslim world and it is possible to take
polling from women by using women
pollsters I mean just like you know just
like when you try to get an on an
airplane in the United States and you're
a woman they'll you know they'll go get
a woman TSA agent to do the cavity
search on you and isn't that wonderful
so no but I mean they can accomplish
polling and from what I understand you
know look here's why I think it's pretty
reliable what I would I would I gather
from it is that in a place like Egypt
it's about 80 percent Islamist and 20
percent secularists in rough numbers
which is what you see in the polling we
had a snapshot
that when they had the referendum during
after Mubarak was asked about when they
were going to have the new constitution
and that election was the campaign was
run as if it were a campaign between the
Muslim Brotherhood position and the
secularist position you know the
Democratic reformers who you know the
people who go up in a balloon about the
Arab Spring want you to believe that the
you know that the Egypt is just bursting
with James al Madison's waiting to
happen right well what what ended up
happening in the election they got wiped
out they lost 78 to 22 which is roughly
the percentage that we're talking about
I don't I don't mean to belittle it we
want the 22 to win we want to do as much
as we can to help the 22 but I don't
think you help the 22 by pretending
they're 80 and closing your eyes and
hoping it works out because you know
things don't work out that way I
actually wish I could have tried cases
that way but I probably wouldn't be here
sir we have time for one more question
hi Andy I thank you as always for your
pleasure
what'd you do last night on Anderson
Cooper on CNN hizzy I missed it
the lead story was about herman cain's
comments about that there are people who
are trying to promote sharia law in this
country and and so the section was
called keeping them honest and he was
trying to show that there was no nothing
to support that and he cited the New
Jersey case that you said he said it was
overturned and then he said they did it
in Oklahoma as well too even though it
was pre-emptive because there was you
know nothing to know Sharia cases or
anything that were even brought up so my
question is how much do you cite the
media is being responsible for stifling
this conversation that you say needs to
happen and how would you rate the job
that they do well look they're enormous
Lee at fault as they as they often are
it's not a it's not a surprise for
example that Sheikh bin Talal who is the
the main financial backer of programs
like the one they have at Harvard for
you know Islamic studies in Sharia law
and the one that they have at Georgetown
is also what is he the second biggest
stockholder now in in News Corp which
runs Fox News I mean they're very
they're very pardon me yeah well I know
I don't know what that was all about but
my point is that whether they are
actually having an effect or not they're
certainly trying and and as I mentioned
in my remarks
bhana thought that controlling the media
and controlling how Islam was presented
to the media and ultimately even
infiltrating the media was an item on
the menu that was just as important as
training for the jihad and in many ways
like controlling the classroom is a way
that you can influence a lot more people
particularly in a western setting so I
can't imagine in terms of the day to day
to day today that the you know the what
people experience about Islam remember
there's only about you know three four
million Muslims in the United States how
many are American Muslims versus
other Muslims like you know I don't know
what the breakdown is but but the point
is that not everybody in America this is
a big old country not not everybody in
America even knows a muzzle most
Americans who know Muslims report and
this has been my own experience that
they're very fine Americans that they
tend to be patriotic you know to the
extent it's not that you give everybody
a quiz about whether they're patriotic
or not but you know they certainly seem
just like every one of us
here's to divide that I saw by the way
as a prosecutor and I think this has
been confirmed again and again over over
the years there's a big divide in the
United States between the rank-and-file
Muslims in the American Muslim community
and the leadership of the mosques and
the Islamic centers if we hadn't had the
help of rank-and-file Muslims we could
not have infiltrated terrorist
organizations in the 90s they helped us
translate the the evidence that we
needed in order to present a case of the
jury a lot of them fight in the arms
forces and in our armed forces and do so
honorably they're just like any one of
us the difference is and I found this
when I tried to hire some as translators
I brought in four people because we had
this big backlog of translations that
the FBI couldn't get to and to get an
FBI translator you have to take them or
something useful like trying to protect
the country from being blown up to do
discovery material you notice that so we
try to hire people from outside and I
had three or four Muslims from the local
Islamic community come in and they knew
why they were there we were preparing a
case against accused Islamic terrorists
and they were perfectly happy to help
the effort the only thing they wanted
was a promise for me that no one would
ever know that they had helped us and
I'm a firm believer that a prosecutor
can't make a promise that that he's not
in a position to honor and in a in a
litigation it's the judge who decides
whether you whether people's names get
revealed or not I told these people that
I do my best
I could see the way I interpreted the
law there was no reason that anyone had
to find out their identities but I
couldn't promise and they all turned us
down
and it turned out that you know it's a
terrorism case so you always think in
the back of people's minds maybe there's
concern about that but what these people
were really concerned about was that the
leadership in their communities would
ostracize them and their families for
working with the United States against
Muslims and it didn't matter that these
were Muslims who had been accused of
conspiring to do mass murder to those
people to the leadership it was very
much in US versus them and you're either
on this side or that side and that's the
way it is what I think we tend to find
is that Muslims living in the United
States just ordinary people tend to be
pro-western and purl American I'm not
saying these are all oversimplifications
but I think in the main that's true the
leadership of the mosques and the
Islamic community centers tends to be
very much influenced by the Muslim
Brotherhood and in fact by outside the
United States forces you know that
that's just in fact in banas plan as he
laid it out the mosque and the Muslim
community center in every town were what
he called the axis of the movement and
it was very important to control them so
it's probably not surprising that you
find this dichotomy between the
leadership and the and the regular folks
but it's a very it's it's troubling
thank you very much great